non
[Musique]
voilà
un homme daniel tremblay bonjour situant
l'action vous anticipe y ait ce voyage
au burkina faso énormément c'était comme
retrouver de vieux amis
c'est peut-être le pays parmi tous ceux
que vous avez visité que vous avez vie
n'est même plus je pense oui
dès mon premier voyage et coup de foudre
pour ce pays là il ya un rythme de vie
ayant une façon d'être
c'est l'instant travail à son bon enfant
ils sont rigueur devra se moquer d'eux
mêmes vraiment je trouve que les
québécois puis les burkinabés le symbole
match et il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'entreprises le québécois ce qui
travaille d'abord un yoyo ne pense pas
être quelqu'un voit des centaines de
personnes d'abord par année alors je
pense que cette affinité les québécois
on aime s'amuser mon âme ce travail est
fort aussi je retrouve ce fait les
burkinabés ça prend quelques jours pour
s'installer dans le nouveau plan le pays
dans lequel on arrive vous avez rendez
vous avec des volontaires d'omg et une
télévision locale
c'est une journée importante au niveau
du volontariat et encore une fois votre
on vous retrouve devant la caméra c'est
un peu que vous êtes une évita
québécoise vous attirer l'attention des
médias pas comment vous faites le monde
est autour de vous vous posez des
questions racontez nous comment ça se
passe avec beaucoup de talent antérieure
au burkina il ya cet animateur de télé
qui est là qui posent des questions et
tout et tout et il ya un chanteur
populaire qui est destiné aux qui est là
sur place et qui fait son scénario qui
chante une chanson et tout est bon mois
l'a fait je vais retrouver des intellos
parce que je trouvais que sa musique
était superbe à leur résister et là je
me retrouve devant la caméra et qui me
demandent mes impressions et là afin
qu'il n'a pas hélas nous sommes allés la
revoir notre ordre la main beloeil
d'abord devoir tenir on vous a vu la
caméra
c'est quelque chose vous êtes devenu une
vedette qu'elle attire moins 15 mai date
c'est râpé je me suis retrouvé en
afrique sud un moment donné à manger mon
sera pas tranquille après 48 heures de
décalage horaire que ça va plus sur
quelle planète gt des couilles des
pygmées des femmes très très très graves
sont venus prendre pour bath avec elle
même c'est toujours comme ça je la
trouve toujours à des situations
abracadabrantes mais qui sont immobiles
à la noix de cajou 10 dollars une fois
gai tomber la cible qu'est ce que c'est
que cette fève qui permet la création de
produits qui sont maintenant présents
demande en occident en fait et noah
vient d'un art qui s'appelle le karité
et c'est un an quand on a peu de
maastricht et il décide lui même de
pousser où bon lui semble alors il ya
des agronomes du travail mais t'as
essayé de domestiquer davantage mais
c'est pas encore fait alors sa demande
que des femmes à et cueillir seynois
l'eau qui tombe comme un peu un olivier
et ça tombe au sol et ce fameux la
ramasse les noix ils reviennent à la
maison avec ça les décortique légèrement
ensuite des ramasseurs vont passer sa
lancée il 5 200 livres lots qui vont
traîner un peu partout comme ça et il ya
des femmes après ceux qui vont faire la
transformation de cette noix là pour
transformer la noix or il faut la faire
bouillir trappe et massez ya des
multiples étapes sont incroyables et qui
sont tout manuel parce que le beurre de
karité méthodes ancestrales
il y à certaines entreprises maintenant
qu'ils ont commencé industrialiser le
processus mais les rames à nutritifs où
les propriétés avec arrêté à 100
affectés
alors ça c'est pour ça que les femmes
qui font du bio ou les femmes qui font
la transformation de manière
traditionnelle sont capables d'avoir un
peu plus d'argent pour leurs produits
un retour que celui qui est
industrialisé mais bon des compagnies
comme l'oréal ou l'autre système et aux
autres ils portent pas de trop quand ça
va dans ton shampoing pour faire une
petite douceur at-on cuir chevelu
on s'en fout un peu mais c'est que les
femmes d'abord c'est un produit qu'on
peut utiliser dans la consommation de
tous les jours c'est un bar et comme
notre huile d'olive concert ici où notre
margarine en peau de vache même chose
essentielle pour la crise on est 20
servent pour l'éclairage est essentielle
pour mettre sur leur peau pour des cons
c'est pour les questions de dermatologie
et s'en servent aussi pour les
nourrissons de 0 à 3 ans l'enfant est
massé deux fois par jour avec du beurre
de karité vous nous expliquer un peu
quand on parle de kilos de tonnes de
production
il ya des chiffres dans votre dans vos
écrits dans votre rapport de mission qui
sont renversants j'aimerais que vous
nous fassiez comprendre l'ampleur de
cette production l'adresse que vous de
ce qui se trouve autour de vous ce que
vous découvrez en arrivant sur place a
fait là-bas dakar était dur qui la baie
a une réputation hors norme
c'est la fin de ce fait il ya d'autres
pays
pas loin le mali est un projet aussi
mais la crème de la crème c'est le
beurre de karité burkina et c'est pour
ça que des grandes entreprises 100 km
entre le standard et al s'approvisionne
pleure parce que la qualité est né là
mais je ne m'attendais pas à des volumes
de cette envergure nos cadets compagnie
de ceux des multinationales quand même
un demi consommatrices achète ça prend
toute une industrie derrière ça
prendrait certainement des milliers de
femmes descendant les champs pour
ramasser la noix puis c'est énorme
chaque petit village aussi assez
curieuse cinq petits villages des
transformatrices alors ce sont des
productions
jeudi matin alors tranquillement il ya
des coopératives qui se sont regroupés
et qui sont capables d'aller chercher
des volumes intéressants pour justement
approcher ces grandes entreprises
moi j'étais là pour justement monter un
regroupement pour tiennent encore plus
grande coopérative pour est capable
d'approcher de plus gros clients encore
une fois vous avez rencontrées vous
l'appelez la reine du karité comme on a
le roi de la patate vous écrivez dans
votre écrit au québec on a le roi de la
patate là bas vous avez découvert la
reine de la qualif du karité qui a été
d'une région peut être la qualité de
notre région mais celle là elle est
reconnue parce que ça fait des années et
c'est à cause d'elle justement qu'elle
aurait elle était capable
s'approvisionner à 4500 sommes sous ses
ordres à 4 ces femmes là elle
travaillait tous de façon un peu
singulière à chacun le monde en tant que
village de qualité c'est normal il avait
toutes les compétences et mais là elle a
réussi à monter des équipes de travail
elle a réussi à monter un centre de
formation à la russie à face à l'or enor
comme elle est possible
il y en a d'autres qui ont fait la même
chose dans d'autres régions suite à ces
formations ne le fait d'essayer de
mettre tout ce monde là à travailler
ensemble pour que en soit capable
d'aller chercher une force de vente
encore plus grande mais c'est pas
toujours fascinant parce qu'il ya des
frictions
il ya des fois où la manne est allé
visiter los zetas à 6,6 et la chicane à
pagny piloter la date il faut que tu
gères sauf qu'il faut que c'est de faire
en sorte que tout le monde s'attend à
part est passée le but ultime c'est la
coopérative alors facile
[Musique]
[Rires]
quel est le résultat de cette campagne
que vous avez menées d'abord est-ce que
ils ont réussi à revendre à d'autres
grandes compagnies qui n'était pas
encore au fait de l'importance de la
qualité de la production du karité n'a
pas pris un deuxième voyage et là on
était plus sur le plan légal de monter
la coopération s'était fait est là tout
le monde s'était mis d'accord il avait
déjà commencé à travailler ensemble sur
un contrat nettoie toutefois une
commande qui était pas capable de faire
tout seul bella commence à danser d un
peu un gros pain croûté l'autre la
confiance commence à se développer
c'était pas facile ou d'être au départ
parce que on se regarde tous un chien de
faïence chacun de son côté puis on s'est
revus moi je fais ça comme ça qui traite
comme ça alors commencé doit travailler
afin d'impulser pas que vous allez
recevoir des gros contrôle du ponant
donner une place à vos collègues que
vous allez apprendre à travailler
ensemble et le feu ça s'est fait sur le
premier voyage d un voyage dans les
têtes plus un terme légal monter la
coopérative comme t elle monter un tracé
d'administration il veut démontrer que
vous devez faire à faire éventuellement
à des fonctionnaires parce que bon quand
vous parlez de questions légales il faut
obtenir des permis payer des taxes
vous êtes là canadienne la north
american esprit pratique qui déteste les
gens qui s'écoute parler surtout parmi
ceux qui croient avoir un peu
d'éducation un peu plus que les autres
c'est qu'ils étaient dans l'action a et
on est d'aller le faire en vue de
saboter sa d'école si on n'a pas le
temps de tergiverser
et là moi je dis que
l'ania liste ne français a fait des
dégâts en afrique parce que vraiment on
tourne en rond on s'écoute parler un
aventure c'est ça la fidi culte et puis
c'est pas mon genre
moi j'aime ça quand on pas pour faire
avancer des choses qui veut faire en
sorte que les choses bougent mais lieu
de parler pour tailler qui est perdu par
les jeux peu de patience pour sauclières
bon j'ai compris on va mettre fin à
cette conversation n'ont cessé depuis
c'est très protocolaire aussi saucisses
et d'herlin de l'époque raffaele les
protocoles 4 fait des soieries à des
galas et que ça une heure et demie à 20
quand on en arrive au jour ce sujet on
avait les discours après les discours et
sous préfets qui vient suivi du se
souche ou préfèrent oui c'est ça moi
j'ai vécu en afrique j'ai été élevé en
afrique je suis un peu responsable de
cette propagation du malaise
écoutez merci beaucoup daniel